.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Seid ihr jetzt bereit?
Eins, zwei, drei!
(Kindervers) Am Waldrand staht ...
Lucien hat einen Traum:
Trotz geistiger
und körperlicher Beeinträchtigung
will er Assistenzlehrer werden.
(Vers)
Im Fänschter brännt es Liechtli.
Sind ächt dört d Chind no wach?
Wie soll das gehen?
Kann er tatsächlich ohne Matura
und trotz diverser Handicaps
zusammen mit
50 regulären Studierenden
an der Pädagogischen Hochschule
eine Ausbildung machen?
Er kann.
Die Idee hatte Matthias Gubler.
Ja, es ist schon ein Tabubruch,
weil ja eigentlich quasi klar ist,
dass man mit
einer kognitiven Beeinträchtigung
sicher nicht studieren kann.
Andererseits gilt
die Idee des lebenslangen Lernens
für uns alle.
Menschen
mit kognitiver Beeinträchtigung
brauchen vielleicht
v.a. etwas länger,
brauchen vielleicht mehr Zeit,
um etwas zu lernen.
Dass man dort sagt,
mit 20 sei Schluss,
ist dann doch auch
eine seltsame Idee.
Das Projekt
haben sie écolsiv getauft,
eine Abkürzung
für Schule und Inklusion.
Kurz vor Abschluss der Ausbildung
besteigt der 30-jährige Luc
mit seinem Studienfreund
Tim Schulthess
in Zürich den Zug nach Wien.
Tim hilft Lucien im Studium
z.B. beim Schreiben
und überall sonst, wo es nötig ist.
Sie sind an eine Konferenz
an der Pädagogischen Hochschule Wien
eingeladen,
um dort das innovative Projekt
aus der Schweiz vorzustellen.
Ich studiere an der Pädagogischen
Hochschule Unterstrass.
Das Studium dauert drei Jahre,
dann bin ich Assistenzlehrer.
Bei seiner Geburt
bekam er zu wenig Sauerstoff
und damit die Diagnose
Zerebralparese.
* Fröhliche Ukulelenmusik *
Der Arzt sagte meiner Mutter,
ich würde nicht gehen, sitzen
oder selbst essen können.
Ich würde 24 Std.
im Rollstuhl sitzen
und immer auf Hilfe angewiesen sein.
Das bin ich natürlich auch,
aber zum Glück weniger.
Bis jetzt ist alles gut gegangen.
Tim Schulthess
wird seine Lehrerausbildung
am selben Tag abschliessen wie Luc.
Er half ihm als Tutor
während der Ausbildung,
wenn Luc an seine Grenzen kam.
Er kann z.B. nicht gut schreiben,
also haben sie
Audiodateien aufgenommen.
Sie mussten oft erfinderisch sein.
Wie reagieren denn
die Kinder auf dich?
Anfangs etwas ängstlich,
und mit der Zeit ...
In der Schule ist es so,
dass sie anfangs eben Zeit brauchen.
Mit der Zeit,
also am zweiten oder dritten Tag,
heisst es dann schon: "Grüezi,
Herr Le, sind Sie auch wieder da?"
"Kommen Sie heute wieder
zu uns in die Klasse?"
Da spürt man, wie gerne sie mich
eigentlich in ihrer Klasse haben.
Kinder haben meist weniger Probleme
mit Menschen wie Luc.
Erwachsene hingegen verhalten sich
in seiner Gegenwart oft verunsichert
und für Luc verletzend,
als sei er
betrunken oder irgendwie ansteckend.
Ich habe auch schon erlebt,
dass ich mich einfach
in den Zug gesetzt habe ...
Es war ein Platz frei,
ich setzte mich hin und sie
stand einfach auf und ging weg.
Das tut dann schon weh,
aber es gehört halt dazu.
Dann sieht man,
wie gross der Charakter ist.
Neben der theoretischen Ausbildung
hatte Luc in den drei Studienjahren
diverse Praktika in Schulklassen
zu absolvieren.
Ja, hereinspaziert. Guten Morgen.
Guten Morgen.
- Hallo, Luc. Geht's gut?
Ja. Dir auch?
- Ja, total.
Ich verteile eben das P - sie haben
einen neuen Buchstaben gelernt.
Bei diesen Erstklässlern unterstützt
er den Lehrer jeweils 2 Std. lang,
immer in der Halbklasse.
Da. Umdrehen.
Du musst es ihm nicht hinlegen,
sondern er soll dranbleiben
und es wieder zurücklegen.
Danke.
Schreibt das erste Wort.
Wir beginnen mit ... Pu-del.
(Kind) Was?
- Pudel.
Pudel.
Hallo. Pudel.
Wo kommt bei "Lampe" das E hin?
Am Schluss.
Lam-pe.
Lampe.
Omar, sag's mal vor -
wieder mit dem Finger.
Ja, geh mal durch.
- (Omar) Lam-pe.
Ja, super. Aufräumen.
Das U fehlt.
Rau...
Raupe.
- Super, du kannst es wegräumen.
Abgeben, wer fertig ist.
- Sehr gut. Raupe.
Es gibt oft Situationen,
in denen ich mich aufteilen möchte.
Ich merke, dass mich Kinder
als Begleiter brauchen.
Das kann ich manchmal
gar nicht bieten.
Das kann er extrem gut machen.
Er ist sehr ... ausdauernd.
Er ist sehr ruhig.
Er bringt Ruhe mit sich.
Er hat starke soziale Kompetenzen -
auch wenn es
nach einer Pause mal Streit gibt,
kann er helfen. Das ist toll.
V.a. dass Kinder
den Fokus behalten können ...
"Was muss ich als Nächstes tun?"
"Wie lasse ich mich
weniger schnell ablenken?"
Da kann er
extrem stark unterstützen.
Manchmal ist es schon enorm wichtig,
dass jemand daneben sitzen
und begleiten kann.
Lucien gefällt es
in diesem Schulhaus so gut,
dass er davon träumt,
hier nach Abschluss der Ausbildung
eine feste Stelle als Assistenzlehrer
zu bekommen.
Hallo zusammen.
Es ging so weit gut.
Ich bin gespannt
auf die zweite Gruppe.
Ja.
- Ich setz dich neben Zejnepe, okay?
Zejnepe? Ja, okay.
- Damit sie den Fokus behält.
Ich habe meine Bewerbung fertig.
- Ja? War das aufwendig?
Nein, also ...
Meine Mutter hat mir geholfen.
Du hast gute Chancen.
Ich würde mich freuen. - Ja?
Ja, logo.
- Warum habe ich gute Chancen?
Du bist gut integriert,
alle kennen dich.
Es ist nicht selbstverständlich,
dass du als Praktikant
beim Teamessen dabei bist
und mit allen weiter gehst.
Du integrierst dich megaschnell.
Ja.
Und ich höre von allen Teams,
dass es sehr gut läuft.
Wie bei uns.
Ich finde, das ist megawertvoll.
Es ist auch
wirklich einfach mit dir.
Wir müssen sehr selten
etwas absprechen.
Ich nehme an,
dass das schon Werbung für dich ist.
Das wird zur Schulleitung
durchdringen.
Ob sie auch die Möglichkeit haben,
weiss ich nicht.
Luc hatte schon Einsätze
bei bis zu Fünftklässlern.
Sein Coach,
ein anderer Lehrer im Schulhaus,
plant die Einsätze mit ihm.
Er ist im dritten Jahr des Studiums.
Jetzt geht es darum, herauszufinden,
wie viel er arbeiten kann,
auf welcher Stufe
er am liebsten arbeitet -
auch, um später in eine Anstellung
übergehen zu können.
Ist es überhaupt realistisch, dass er
hier im Schulhaus anfangen könnte?
Das wird im Moment abgeklärt.
Es ist auch Sache der Stadt
und der Kreisschulbehörde,
diese Anstellungsbedingungen
zu schaffen.
Was heisst das?
Es gibt im Bereich Schule momentan
keine Anstellungsbedingungen
für Menschen mit einer Behinderung.
Lohnklasse, Lohnkategorie - all das
muss jetzt entwickelt werden.
Im Zug nach Wien
erinnert sich Luc daran,
wie er zehn Jahre lang
in einer geschützten Werkstatt
die immer gleiche Arbeit
erledigt hat.
Es gab verschiedene Grössen
von Spiesschen -
sehr grosse und kleine -
und Zahnstocher.
Man musste sie von Hand abfüllen.
Oder man hatte ein Stück Holz
mit 100 Löchern.
Da musste man ...
... ja einen Zahnstocher
oder einen Spiess reintun,
dann das nächste -
einfach auffüllen.
Und dann wieder einpacken.
Und das 100'000-mal.
Was ich jetzt machen kann,
ist auch für mich ...
... Gold wert.
Es ist viel mehr wert.
Und es macht viel mehr Spass.
* Ruhige Gitarrenmusik *
Sauberer Jump.
Ich finde unseren Bahnhof schöner,
das ist schon mal klar.
Kannst du dann bitte
die Flasche nehmen? Danke.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
ob das stimmt.
Derweil an der PH Unterstrass
in Zürich.
Die 33-jährige Christina Raissig
ist ebenfalls Studentin
im Projekt écolsiv.
Hallo zusammen.
Von Geburt an
hat sie eine linksseitige Lähmung.
Neben ihrer Lernbehinderung
hört sie auf einem Ohr nichts.
Ausserdem hatte sie vor einiger Zeit
einen Hirnschlag.
Jede Woche
holen alle angehenden Lehrer/-innen
im Schulhaus nebenan ein Kind ab,
um 1 Std. mit ihm zu üben.
* Stimmengewirr *
Cleo.
Kapuze.
- Ja.
Hattest du schöne Ferien?
Das Thema ist Körper.
Christina ist jetzt
im zweiten Ausbildungsjahr
zur Assistenzlehrerin.
Weisst du, was das ist?
Das Institut nimmt jährlich ein bis
zwei beeinträchtigte Studierende
ins Projekt écolsiv auf.
Das ist ein Massband.
- Ja.
Was kann man
mit diesem Massband machen?
Man kann messen.
- Sollen wir dich messen?
Sollen wir dich mal messen?
Willst du nicht?
Nein.
- Was dann?
Willst du etwas anderes machen?
Ja.
- Gut, schauen wir weiter.
Mach aus der Knete mal einen Körper.
Du kannst auch eine Schnecke machen.
Weisst du was?
Wir machen eine Schnecke kaputt.
Ich mache hier mal ... Gut.
Wow, das ist eine schöne Schnecke.
Soll ich diesen mal vorbereiten?
Christina ist verpflichtet,
an allen Lektionen teilzunehmen.
Wie bei Luc geht es auch bei ihr
nicht ohne Unterstützung
durch ihre Mitstudierenden.
Wie ist es
heute Nachmittag gelaufen?
Konntet ihr das Thema anschneiden?
Sind die Kinder darauf eingestiegen?
Am Anfang war Cleo ziemlich nervös.
Sie wusste eigentlich nicht,
was der Körper ist.
Ich habe dann langsam begonnen, ab-
zutasten, was der Körper sein kann.
Mit Bildern und allem.
Wir haben gezeichnet
und auch selbst geknetet.
Sie hat
eine megasüsse Schnecke gemacht.
Also ist sie gleich
auf das Knetmaterial eingestiegen?
Da hat sie
einen Ansatzpunkt gefunden.
Pascale und ich haben beide gemerkt,
dass Himmelskörper dazu
noch nicht so ... geeignet sind.
Also zur Angewöhnung.
Und bei Lena
weiss ich es nicht so genau.
Ja, mein Kind weiss halt
schon recht genau, was es möchte.
* Lachen *
Das ist einerseits toll,
aber ich habe gemerkt,
dass sie für andere Ideen
nicht so offen ist.
Sie ist dann in dieser Schiene.
Für die Studierenden ist wichtig,
dass auch die Dozentinnen
hinter dem écolsiv-Projekt stehen.
Das Ziel des Ganzen ist,
das Kind wahrzunehmen.
Ich will ihr den Mut geben,
dass sie das unabhängig
von ihren anderen Fähigkeiten kann.
Dass sie lernt ...
- ... mutig auf andere zuzugehen
und dass das,
was sie bringt, auch genügt.
Selbstvertrauen, denke ich.
Ich sehe,
wie das bei ihr gewachsen ist.
Die Selbstsicherheit. Sie will sich
auch bei Gruppenarbeiten einbringen.
Man muss schon noch mal besprechen,
was ihre Aufgabe ist -
es ist nicht wie die Arbeit
mit anderen Studenten.
Aber sie übernimmt
immer mehr Verantwortung,
kann sich immer mehr eingeben,
und es ist auch schön, zu sehen,
wenn sie sich freut,
weil etwas geklappt hat.
Mein Ziel ist,
in der Unterstufe Schule zu geben.
Also in einem Jahr,
wenn dort wieder
eine Stelle frei ist.
In Wien
gilt es für Lucien und Tim ernst.
Inzwischen ist auch die Projekt-
leiterin aus der Schweiz angereist.
Dann begrüsse ich euch herzlich
zu unserem Vortrag.
Herzlich willkommen.
Wir sind vom écolsiv-Team
aus der Schweiz.
Mein Name ist Lucien Le.
Ich bin als Luc angeschrieben.
Ich bin der erste Student, der in
fünf Monaten offiziell abschliesst.
Dann bin ich offiziell
Assistenzlehrer ...
... für Kinder und Jugendliche.
Das Interesse in Wien
ist noch bescheiden,
was Lucs Enthusiasmus über seine
Ausbildung in keiner Weise schmälert.
Das war gar nicht ich.
Gerne möchte er sich
beim Leiter der Inklusionsabteilung
für die Einladung an die Tagung
bedanken.
Hallo.
- (Leiter) Hallo.
Grüss Sie, Herr Le.
- Grüezi.
Hallo, grüss Sie.
Schön, dass Sie bei der Inklusions-
forscherinnentagung in Wien sind.
Danke für die Einladung.
- Gern geschehen. Freut mich.
Herr Le,
mich würde z.B. interessieren,
wie es Ihnen mit dem Studieren,
mit dem Lernen gegangen ist.
Die ersten vier Wochen
nachdem ich angefangen hatte,
waren sehr hart.
Man muss sehr viele
neue Informationen aufnehmen -
wo man sein muss, wann man
in der Schule antanzen muss ...
Es waren extrem viele Informationen.
Mein Kopf war sehr voll
und hat ab und zu auch geraucht.
Das war sehr viel,
aber es hat Spass gemacht.
Auch meine Klasse
hat mir sehr viel geholfen.
Ich hätte eine zweite Frage,
wenn ich darf.
Natürlich.
Was haben Sie vor, nachdem Sie
den Lehrgang abgeschlossen haben?
Ich will Assistenzlehrer sein.
Ich werde für die Kinder da sein,
die schwächer sind
oder die Handicaps haben.
Kinder mit Lernschwächen.
Wir haben sehr viele Kinder
mit Lernschwächeproblemen.
Ich habe ja auch
ein Handicap beim Reden
und ich kann z.B.
nicht so gut gehen.
Ich brauche auch Zeit.
Kinder,
die z.B. eine Lernschwäche haben,
brauchen auch Zeit,
aber das ist kein Grund, nicht in
die normale Schule gehen zu können.
Wir hatten hier an der
Pädagogischen Hochschule in Wien
vor einigen Jahren
ein ähnliches Projekt,
den sog. Empowerment-Lehrgang,
bei dem Menschen
mit verschiedensten
Beeinträchtigungen
wie beim Projekt écolsiv
gemeinsam mit Studierenden
an der Pädagogischen
Hochschule Wien studiert
und einen Lehrgang absolviert haben.
Ich möchte
diesen Empowerment-Lehrgang
auch wieder implementieren.
Da greife ich gerne
auf Erfahrungen von écolsiv zurück.
Danke schön.
- Herr Le, alles Gute.
Ihnen auch. Viel Erfolg ...
- Danke schön.
... bei Ihrem Neustart.
- Danke.
Bitte.
Gut, dann: Wiederschauen.
- Adieu.
Das hast du gut gemacht.
Ein paar Wochen später steht Luc
ein wichtiges Gespräch bevor -
wegen Corona per Zoom
in seiner Wohnung.
Die Schulleiterinnen
im Schulhaus Luchswiesen
haben seine Bewerbung geprüft
und sich entschieden.
Heute wird Luc erfahren,
ob er die Stelle
als Assistenzlehrer bekommt.
Jetzt mache ich eigentlich meine
Anstellung für die Zukunft klar.
Hallo, Maestro. Wie geht's?
- Hallo.
Gut.
- Gut.
Wie geht's euch?
- Heute ist der gute Anlass.
Unterstützt
wird er von seinem Stiefvater,
der gleichzeitig
als Beistand fungiert.
Hallo, Luc.
- Hallo.
Wir begrüssen dich herzlich
zu diesem Vorstellungsgespräch.
Wir haben uns sehr
über deine Bewerbung gefreut.
Danke.
Wir wollen jetzt einfach abholen,
was du dir vorstellst.
Lohnmässig wäre es gut, wenn ich
einen Monatslohn bekommen würde -
so zwischen 500 und 600 Fr.
Das wäre super.
Wenn es eine Anstellung gibt,
dann sicher mit Monatslohn.
Das sind Dinge, die so sein sollten.
Aber Simone hat vorhin erklärt:
Die Behörden sind da noch dran.
Darum können wir darüber
keine Aussagen machen.
Wir melden uns dann gerne
noch einmal bei dir.
Wir würden so verbleiben ...
Ich habe es vorhin schon gesagt:
Wir können dir
einen Praktikumsplatz zusichern.
Sobald wir in Bezug
auf den Vertrag mehr wissen,
laden wir dich und deinen Beistand
noch einmal ein.
Dann gibt es noch ein Gespräch,
bei dem administrative Dinge
im Vordergrund stehen.
Dann können wir das besprechen.
Wir stehen im Austausch
mit den Behörden,
damit wir bald
zu einer Lösung kommen
und dich auch regelkonform
unbefristet als Klassenassistent
einstellen können.
Zusammengefasst:
Er hat eine Zusage ohne Vertrag,
weil es die Assistenzlehrerstelle
bzw. die entsprechenden Formulare
dazu noch nicht gibt.
Aber Luc wäre nicht Luc,
wenn er diese Mitteilung
nicht positiv auslegen würde.
Es ist eine sehr gute Schule,
und ich bin sehr froh,
dass ich dort bald
Teil des Teams sein darf.
Ich dachte immer, ich würde nie
von der geschützten Insel wegkommen.
Das ist jetzt wirklich
die ganz grosse Chance,
dass ich von dieser Insel weg
und in den
normalen Arbeitsmarkt gehen kann.
Ich habe beim Gespräch mit ihnen
gespürt, dass sie das unterstützen
und dass sie die Arbeit mögen,
die ich ihnen bieten kann.
Also dass sie sie
gerne entgegennehmen.
Gut, also.
Ich gratuliere dir auf jeden Fall.
Lucien ist stolz,
dass er allein wohnen kann.
Möglich machen das die IV
und bauliche Anpassungen.
Das habe ich extra machen lassen.
Das ist meine Küche.
Da sind die Früchte drin -
und natürlich Bier.
Über die Werkbank
habe ich vorhin gesprochen.
Die hat mein Stiefvater entworfen.
Ich stelle die hier rein ...
... und mache zu.
Das ist eigentlich ein Nussknacker.
Den braucht man für Nüsse.
So.
Nicht, dass Sie glauben,
ich wäre ein Alki.
Ja, ich trinke gerne Bier.
Aber ich habe es voll im Griff.
Da ist der Föhn.
Den brauche ich, um meine Haare
und den Rücken zu föhnen.
Dafür wurde er extra
da oben hingebaut.
Man stellt sich hier hin ...
... und macht einfach ...
* Der Föhn rauscht. *
Das ist schon alles.
Ich bin nicht so gerne
immer von anderen abhängig.
Natürlich
brauche ich im Leben Hilfe,
aber wenn ich gerade
nicht so viel Hilfe brauche,
bin ich auch froh,
wenn ich mal allein bin
und fast alles allein machen kann.
Gewisse haben ja die Spitex,
und bei mir ist es einfach so,
dass ich es mir leisten kann ...
... Assistenten zu haben,
die vorbeikommen.
Dann kann ich sagen: "Ich wäre froh,
wenn ihr jetzt kommen würdet."
Ich bin froh, dass ich nicht morgens
um 8 Uhr auf der Matte stehen muss,
wenn die von der Spitex kommen.
Er kann keine Karriere
in dem Sinne machen,
aber er kann sich
ein anständiges Wohnen leisten.
Und es ist nicht selbstverschuldet,
darum spricht ihm die IV
Assistenzleistungen zu -
Hilfen, die er nicht braucht.
Bei einem Wohnheim
wie der Wohnschule
oder der WG, in der er war,
zahlt die IV einfach Beiträge
an diese Institution.
Und ihm wird das jetzt
direkt ausgezahlt.
Damit kann er sich
einige Assistenten leisten,
die für das Wichtigste nötig sind.
So kann er anständig leben.
Also, Viva, Jüngling.
Zum Wohl.
- Zum Wohl.
Auf die Zukunft.
Über seine Zukunft muss jetzt
der zuständige Stadtrat entscheiden,
der gerade informiert wird.
Es geht um die Integration eines
jungen Mannes mit Beeinträchtigung
in den ersten Arbeitsmarkt.
Der junge Mann
hat am Institut Unterstrass
die Ausbildung
zum Klassenassistenten gemacht.
Es geht darum,
dass wir diesen jungen Mann
bei der Stadt Zürich
einstellen könnten.
Da stellen sich einige Fragen.
Ich finde sehr gut,
dass wir das versuchen.
Man muss einfach schauen, wie das
in ein Vertragskonstrukt passt -
und dann ist da
vermutlich noch die Lohnfrage.
Mhm.
- Worauf würde man da zielen?
Das spielt immer
eine wichtige Rolle.
Eine Klassenassistenz
verdient in der Stadt Zürich
im Durchschnitt netto 65'000 Fr.
Von dort
würde ich dann rückwärts rechnen.
So würde ich seinen Lohn festlegen.
Ein unbeschränkter Arbeitsvertrag
wäre in einer solchen Pilotphase
nicht ganz einfach.
Aber man müsste prüfen,
ob das möglich wäre.
Wir von der Stadt
haben die wichtige Aufgabe,
gerade solchen Leuten
eine Chance zu bieten.
Aber sie muss echt sein.
Leistung, Lohn, Belastbarkeit -
das muss alles übereinstimmen.
Darum finde ich,
dass es eine Testphase geben muss,
in der man schaut,
wie sich das entwickelt.
* Dynamische Musik *
Lucien ist oft allein unterwegs,
und seine wenigen Freunde
sollte er wegen Corona
jetzt sowieso nicht treffen.
Seine Auftritte als DJ
fallen ebenfalls weg.
Aber sein Stammlokal
ist ihm sehr wichtig.
Nicht nur, weil er wegen
seiner Behinderung nicht kochen kann,
kommt er fast täglich hierher.
Hallo, Hüs.
- Hallo, Luc.
Wie geht's?
- Gut, danke. Dir? Alles gut?
Ich möchte einen Kebab-Teller.
- Kebab-Teller, gerne.
Welche Salatsauce hättest du gerne?
- Französisch.
Das ist wie mein zweites Zuhause.
Ich bin fast jeden Tag hier.
Weil er mich ...
- Er ist unser Stammgast.
... zu seiner Hochzeit
eingeladen hat.
Und er ist ein Freund.
Luc, darf ich bitten?
Danke.
- So, bitte schön.
Wissen Sie, was er beruflich macht?
- Lehrer.
Beratungslehrer, oder?
- Ja.
Er kommt jeden Tag her.
Er ist unser Freund.
Guten Appetit.
- Danke schön.
Danke dir.
Luc beschwert sich nie
über Einsamkeit,
aber die Sehnsucht nach
einer Partnerin kennt er natürlich.
Meine Traumfrau muss nicht
aussergewöhnlich schön sein,
sie muss einfach das gewisse
Etwas haben, das mich anspricht.
Sie muss selbstbewusst sein,
denn das muss ich auch.
Ohne mein Selbstbewusstsein
hätte ich nicht ...
... bis jetzt überleben können.
So muss sie auch sein.
Ich habe es versucht,
und ich bin meistens abgeblitzt.
Irgendwann habe ich
keine Kraft mehr, hinterherzurennen.
Es macht sowieso keinen Sinn.
Es nicht einfach,
wenn man behindert ist.
Beruflich
hat er eine riesige Hürde geschafft.
Er ist zertifizierter Assistenzlehrer
mit Diplom.
* Pfiffe, Jubel *
* Anhaltender Applaus *
Was das für seine Mutter bedeutet,
ist ihr deutlich anzusehen.
Als Luc zur Welt kam,
hätte ich mir nie vorstellen können,
dass er mal ein Studium machen,
Assistenzlehrer werden
und sogar eine Stelle finden würde.
Das hätte ich mir wirklich
nie vorstellen können.
Komm.
- Ja, Mama.
Ich muss ihn
noch ein wenig knuddeln.
Mami hör auf.
Wir dürfen das.
- Mami hör auf.
Er ist sicher
ein sehr authentischer Mensch.
Er scheut sich nicht,
zu sagen,
was er will oder was er denkt.
Es gibt auch Dinge, die wir denken,
aber nicht aussprechen,
und er sagt es dann
und nimmt Stellung dazu.
Ich fand den Perspektivenwechsel
sehr spannend und bereichernd.
Gestern sagte er: "Ich brauche
eine Hand, die für mich schreibt."
Er meldet sich
und weiss genau, was er braucht.
Das hilft auch uns Mitschülern
dabei, ihn zu integrieren
und zu wissen,
wie man es ihm einfacher machen
und mit ihm arbeiten kann.
Er ist ein Mensch wie wir - das hat
sich hier einmal mehr gezeigt.
Ich hatte sogar das Glück, in einer
Klasse mit ihm arbeiten zu dürfen.
Es war megaspannend,
die Kinder beobachten zu dürfen.
Anfangs waren sie noch
sehr misstrauisch und verwundert,
weil sie noch nie mit so jemandem
Kontakt gehabt hatten.
Durch die ganzen Fragen,
die sie stellten
und die er
sehr ehrlich beantwortete,
wurde es selbstverständlich.
Am Ende war es, als wäre da nichts.
Mir ist noch was eingefallen.
Das war eine der ersten Weisheiten,
die du von Nonna gelernt hattest.
Als du klein warst, sagtest du:
"Geduld bringt Rosen."
Das ist mir heute eingefallen,
als du diese Rose bekommen hast.
Du hattest so viel Geduld.
Es hat so lange gedauert,
dann wurdest du integriert.
Jetzt bist du an diesem Ort.
Ich finde es so schön,
dass du diese Rose bekommen hast.
Danke, Mami.
Den Vertrag
hat er inzwischen bekommen.
Für 70 % verdient Lucien Le
1'008 Fr. pro Monat
als erster
beeinträchtigter Assistenzlehrer
mit Diplom und fester Anstellung -
wenn auch vorerst
befristet auf ein Jahr.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Daniel McMinn - 2020